what is up guys this is an epic market
so I'm gonna go ahead and trade I'll try
to talk a little bit but this is gonna
require some pretty silent maneuvering
and that didn't work sorry guys I
intended to just talk while I tried it
through the whole thing but I just
couldn't do it
I was it was pretty much constant making
moves and setting up next steps and all
that and it got quiet pretty quick so
what I'm gonna do instead is just kind
of talk over the video I've sped it up
significantly videos about 33 minutes
long and scrunched it to about like nine
ten minutes so so yeah so what I'm just
going to talk about is some stuff that
I've found trading Bitcoin and all that
so this session was completely hand
traded obviously I do admit I do plan to
make a trading bot but that's still very
much in the development stages so
generally with Bitcoin I've had pretty
good results just simply trading the
simple moving average crossovers now I
know that's kind of silly uh-huh but it
actually works whenever it's low volume
trading but even in the high volume
trading it works it's just not
necessarily the most profitable trading
practice for me so probably my first
trading bot that I make I probably will
just use a machine learning algorithm to
pick the simple moving averages that
work best maybe make the moving averages
vary by volume possibly but I'll just
I'll do that and probably make the bot
based off something very similar to that
so anyway that's pretty interesting so
some of the other things I've learned at
least like if you're going to trade via
crossovers is at least with a Bitcoin
wisdom you want to make sure you're
watching the simple moving average line
and if you're trading crossovers you
wouldn't want to trade the crossover
until the next bar comes out so so what
happens is they're constantly generating
the most up-to-date information there
and so what will what can happen to you
is you'll get a you know bar and it
looks like it's crossover and you should
make the trade but the bar is not done
being made so there best bar is a
one-minute bar so what can happen is you
know 30 seconds into that minute it
could drop down cause the crossover line
the cross o or the lines to cross over
but then in the last 30 seconds the
price goes up again and no we actually
didn't get a crossover at all so that
kind of stuff can happen and it can kind
of like trip you up you know so you
might like be like okay there's a
crossover make the trade you make the
trade and then like it reverses and
you're like what the heck and then you
reluck at it you're like I think there
was never a crossover what the heck and
so you can kind of get fooled and it
might make you think that it's changing
the line on you or something but anyway
I thought I would just make it clear
that that is not what's happening it's
just that you have to pay attention to
you know the bar finishing so that's at
least one thing I would tell you guys to
watch out for I'm pretty happy with this
Bitcoin wisdom website they've got a
really good connection to their API
Bitcoin wisdom itself has never gone
down for me the only time it's ever
stopped giving prices is when the API is
themselves go down so I'm pretty happy
there other than that I will just kind
of bring up my trading style I'm sure
some of you guys might be able to think
of a better method than what I've done
but what I ended up doing is there's a
way on btc-e if you go to your finances
you can view trade history and order
history well trade history will show you
the you know transacted trades order
history will show you any current orders
that are standing and so what I tend to
do is I'll place the order refresh the
order page and I'll just stare at the
price on Bitcoin wisdom and anytime it
hits a price at or below or at or above
my offer depending on what kind of offer
it is I know it's completed I'll refresh
to make sure and because you know you
can sell maybe 5% instead of the whole
thing you thought you sold it all but
you didn't but if the price obviously
passes your price then you do know
you've sold a hundred percent and
sometimes I won't check it like if I see
that the price is passed there's no
reason to check it so I just go and do
my next offer that brings me to the next
point I go ahead and pre fill all of the
fields
prior so I'll make the offer and then
I'll fill the Buy and the sell or like
let's say I made a buy right so the next
action in theory would be a sell right
so what I'll end up doing is if I made a
buy I'm in the selling mode so I'll make
a sell sell and then the next step would
have been a buy correct but what I end
up doing is I'll make a buy right what
for whatever you know margin I need and
then I'll also make a sell and I do that
just in case price starts running away
on me I can cancel my current sell and
sell or if my cell is filled I'm able to
immediately make a buy so both both ways
it keeps you able it keeps you on your
toes basically to be able to make
extreme changes or any of your changes
really very quickly and at least with
btc-e I haven't gotten confirmed on
mount GOx yet so I have no idea about
the trade speed on Mount GOx um and I I
sent in that stuff like I don't even
know man I swear it's been two weeks but
maybe not anyway so I don't know about
their trade speed but at least on btc-e
I don't think any transactions actually
occurring I don't think that they're
doing anything besides updating numbers
in a database I think it's only when you
actually go to move your money that
anything official actually occurs
because the money gets moved so fast
here
I just find it is pretty impressive to
say the least so anyways that's just a
couple of ideas as far as like my trades
set up and what I end up doing like I
said I'm sure somebody can probably
think of a better setup than that but
yeah so the other thing I just want to
bring up is you know how this session
even came about so you normally I'm just
training throughout the day and I'm
trading simple move it out simple moving
average crossovers that's it and I've
done pretty well doing that and the only
time I haven't done well is when I don't
follow those rules as you know that's
typical with traders right as soon as
you decide to not follow your own rules
you do get smacked for it and the only
time I would ever change up and the only
time I do change up that trading
practice is in high-volume scenarios so
this trading session right here was one
highest volume trading sessions I've
ever even taken part in it was pretty
epic and other you know you can have you
know half of this volume and still
ignore any crossovers and if you really
wanted to I guess you would just you
know decrease the actual duration of the
simple moving average and that's kind of
like what I was thinking of doing for my
my trade bot
whenever I start start making it so
anyway those are just a couple ideas so
the last thing I really like to mention
if you're going to be engaging in
trading is that you have to be careful
about the fees so you can kind of
because you're getting feed in like your
bitcoins so each time you're making your
offers you might think you have so many
Bitcoin but you're actually you've been
you know your Bureau it's taking away a
little bit of Bitcoin every trade right
so at least on btc-e it's 0.2% so every
trade all right you got to be careful
because you're gonna be losing Bitcoin
slowly and so you might be like here in
this trading session we started with
like 0.29 Bitcoin I think and we end it
with more like 0.3 for Bitcoin purely
because just out of profit but there
were times where I thought I had 0.34
but it would be like oh you don't have
enough Bitcoin and so I'd have to edit
that offer to 0.33 and so the way I've
gone about dealing with this is you know
if you're using a program then that's no
problem you just trade the full amount
every time no problem but if you're
doing it by hand you you gotta just you
got to be able to just guesstimate you
know the best numbers to choose and so
if this is you then the best way to
handle this at least in my opinion
informal I found is you know if the
trend is upward then you don't really
need to worry about extra Bitcoin coming
in to your coffers right so usually I'll
just kind of in my head just be like
okay a little bit less like 0.01 less or
0.001 less every trade I'll just keep
doing that every time I trade and then
when it starts to hit a tipping point
where I'm like I'm not so comfortable
anymore and I'm ready to just like let
it kind of fall down a little bit then
I'll I'll make my cell or
make my buy I'll refresh the page to see
how much do I need to sell and then I'll
actually you know do the sell and sell
like the full amount of Bitcoin so in
that sense like when you're ready to you
know get out and let it drop for a
little bit you've got plenty of time
right so you might as well just kind of
refresh the page look at how much you
got enter the full amount sell and then
walk away you know and it's usually
worth it you might lose a couple dollars
or something on the you know per Bitcoin
but that's generally the way I've gone
about dealing with that like slow
degradation of your Bitcoin or the slow
increase of your Bitcoin even so if
you're doing good you're probably
actually increasing Bitcoin alright and
then what do you want to do with that is
get rid of it once you think the price
is going to decline so anyways the next
thing I want to show you guys is my
profit for this session so what I did is
I took the trading session which is
taken from my profile here and actually
starts at this point here so that's
where we began the trading session and
then we made all of these trades and it
all occurred in about 30 minutes so
pretty eventful trading session for 30
minutes quite a few trades there and so
what I would have had to did and just
copy and pasted it and separated by
bison cells into a spreadsheet here so I
could get you know my actual earnings so
in this session I traded a total of
three thousand nine hundred twenty nine
dollars and ninety three cents I bought
that much I sold three thousand nine
hundred dollars and for three thousand
nine hundred forty nine dollars and 38
cents for that difference of 19.4 T five
cents for a seven point eight percent
profit which in you know the time frame
of thirty minutes is not bad at all
so even though yes bitcoin is very
volatile it still makes for a very fun
fun little thing to trade whatever you
want to call it currency commodity thing
whatever that was enjoyable so anyways
hopefully you guys enjoyed it if you do
enjoy these trading sessions I can do
more of them live like that I just do
those if they're you know
infiltrating session the problem is so
many of them have been just very
uneventful hopefully you guys didn't
mind that I wasn't talking through the
training session I tried my best to
start the video off talking and I was
just like you know what I just can't do
it
oh hopefully you didn't mind so I just
kind of voiced over the video as it was
happening so anyways hopefully that
wasn't too bad if you guys did enjoy it
let me know in the comments and I can
maybe make some more of these kinds of
videos maybe give some more tips and
pointers and stuff as far as trading
bitcoins concerned so anyways hopefully
you guys enjoy it hopefully you're
enjoying your stay with Bitcoin good
luck with whatever you intend on doing
as always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support the subscriptions and
the donations and it's all next time